here's a really funny story about Bill
O'Reilly we haven't talked about Bill
O'Reilly for a little while this is of
course the Fox News television host of
The O'Reilly Factor hugely popular show
Bill O'Reilly who is very proud of his
Irish roots has threatened to move to
Ireland if Democratic Socialist Bernie
Sanders is elected president of the
United States he doesn't want anything
to do with democratic socialism here's
what bill actually said if Bernie
Sanders gets elected president I'm
fleeing I'm going to Ireland and they
already know it I shouldn't say it
publicly because that will get Sanders
more votes but I'm not going to pay
ninety percent of my income to that guy
I'm sorry I'm not doing it let's break
this down Louis first and foremost the
90% thing is absurd the fact that people
keep saying that is really confusing low
information voters when you talk about a
marginal tax rate for the top income
bracket which Bernie isn't likely to be
able to put at ninety percent even if he
tried even if he became president
that's a marginal tax rate so you still
pay on your first twenty fifty hundred
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in income you pay the same percentage as
anybody else who earns that amount of
money on the money you earn above and
beyond that top tax rate you would pay
that top tax bracket and that's the
source of a lot of confusion let's
forget that for now
Bill O'Reilly clearly has no idea what
Ireland is like today and if he's trying
to avoid democratic socialism in the
United States
Ireland is not the place that he should
be going number one the top marginal tax
rate currently in Ireland is higher than
here in the United States number two
even if Bill O'Reilly moved to Ireland
current rules wouldn't allow him to
avoid US taxes anyway you still have to
pay American taxes even if you what's
the term I'll renounce your citizenship
now you arguably still owe some taxes to
the United States although some people
would would say that they just wouldn't
pay them but the idea that he's gonna
avoid any US taxes by going to Ireland
is not by any means edged in stone gun
control Ireland is way tougher on gun
control than the United States and Bill
O'Reilly has talked many times about
his love for the First Amendment and his
right to protect himself it is going to
be pretty tough to get guns in Ireland
because they are highly restricted many
cops don't even carry firearms in
Ireland and then here's the really big
one Louis socialized medicine Ireland
has socialized medicine this is the type
of thing Bernie Sanders wants Bill
O'Reilly seems to know very little about
Ireland uh did you mention nationwide
legal gay marriage too right yeah okay
well I think O'Reilly okay with that I
don't know he doesn't he's not big
against gay marriage at least not
recently all right well yeah it's you
know maybe he just really likes the
Irish countryside but certainly if you
are trying to avoid all of the things we
talked about Ireland would not be the
place they are more conservative than
than a lot of other parts of Europe
that's prepared to the United States
right now other than on abortion Ireland
is not a very conservative place no but
I'm sure Bill O'Reilly would have a
great time and I don't think any of us
would be sad to see him go and it may
not even be that easy for him to get in
there because the if you have a
grandparent who's Irish you can get
Irish citizenship my understanding is
Bill O'Reilly closest Irish relative was
a great grandparent so it's not even
clear that he can do this which may be a
saving grace for his ignorance on the
issue because it is by no means a
conservative paradise over there